[Music]
so ifs internal family systems
founded by richard schwartz
uh he may be
dick schwartz
the podcast notes i've had him on the
podcast
is a framework for
not just interpersonal
communications but also therapy and
trauma work
where you identify different aspects of
the self that's the internal family part
that's the reference and it's very
very powerful for
trauma work that's where i have the most
familiarity
so for people who want more on that they
can just search
my name or
or ifs at tim dot blog podcast that's a
good idea to to name it because i it
also it also buys a little bit of time
and it provides a window into
the felt experience without leaping
directly to an argument that's right
it's kind of announcing the players on
the stage before the players start
talking yeah there's a way in which
you're stepping to what we would call
the third position
like to a balcony
to name what's going on yeah could you
say more about that yeah
so we talk about really skilled
communicators and negotiators developing
first position skills second position
skills and third position skills so
first position skills are how self-aware
are you of what's going on for you what
meaning you're making of things
different
emotions you're bringing to the table or
identity issues etc and can you
share them clearly and skillfully
second position skills are how good are
you at stepping into someone else's
shoes and imagining the world as they
see it and and finding a way to get
yourself to genuine curiosity if i can
get from that's
crazy
to i wonder why you think something like
that which feels crazy well that's at
least a step in the right direction so
those are empathy skills
and also letting them know that you
understand or that you're working to
understand it anyway
and third position skills are can i step
above the fray and name what's happening
like like that's what the
couples are doing in the gottman work
which is to like just admit i am good
and you are bad that's what's really
going on here like you're naming
our usual escalation pattern
so in the book we talk about stepping to
the third position starting a
conversation from the third position
which is i know that you and i struggle
with a difference
or i know we feel differently about how
we talk to each other for instance or i
know that it makes me crazy when the
dishes are not done before everyone goes
to bed and food sits on the table which
i think is disgusting and i know that
after dinner you just want to relax
and so it's your turn to do the dishes
the food does sit i and i wonder what we
should do about that so you're naming
my there's a difference between how i
prefer things and how you prefer things
and the conversation is about
just better understanding than what we
should do about it that that's a
promising way to
start a conversation
it's also related to what we call the
and stance
and there are a couple different kinds
of ands there's
what we call the you me and
i know you prefer it this way and i
prefer it another way
i know that you find it hard when i'm
harsh or direct or make unilateral
decisions
and
i find it hard when you accuse me of
being selfish when i do that since i
don't think that's really what's going
on what should we do about that
i know you feel upset and betrayed and
let down by me and i feel wrongly
accused and upset and betrayed that you
would think that of me that we can both
be upset at the same time so that's the
yumi and
then there's another thing called a me
me and and this is much more what dick
schwartz i think is talking about which
is that
i love you and admire how skillful
you've brought this up and care that i
have once again upset or hurt you and
and
i'm also mad at you for bringing it up
now
and i'm
worried and frustrated that i don't
think i'm gonna be able to sleep and i
feel partly wrongly accused or
misunderstood at least
and so i feel conflicted
and the feelings if we're going to step
into the feelings conversation part of
difficult conversations
often there's a headline feeling
or there's a feeling i think i'm
supposed to have right now but
underneath that are a whole bundle of
conflicting and mixed feelings and
sometimes sorting them out and i think
this is part of
what dick schwartz is is helping people
do with ifs which is to sort out the
parts of them that feel differently so
it's not just a soupy murky mess yes i
love you and i'm mad at you right now
yeah yeah we sometimes give people two
chairs
and like put the positive feelings here
and in this other chair put the negative
feelings there say what you want to say
to them and when you move between chairs
you need to spend time in each chair and
when you move between chairs use the
word and not but
because usually we'll say i love you but
you're driving me crazy you know that
negates the first statement yeah they
say bud is the great eraser so it feels
like
the first part is just easing in the
second part is what this is really about
when in fact often it both things are
equally true
which is why and helps
you